less than six months though every
american you the american people have
the opportunity to let your voices be
heard and i hope it's loud and i hope
it's clear we have got to right the ship
which is our country because the past 18
months less than 18 months under joe
biden it has been one failure after
another they pole tested ultra magga
okay we have an ultra failure as a
president it's a disaster on every level
look at the new york post calling it
quote joe's train wreck on that that's
today's cover of the new york post and
it listed the crisis from this week
alone gas hitting what i think we're 10
days in a row now with gas prices
setting one new record after another and
a brutal six dollar a gallon prediction
coming i'll get to in a second the
border crisis gets worse the ministry of
truth has collapsed thankfully anyway
the market drops what 1164 points the
worst day in two years
and we're short of baby formula oh but
don't worry the biden administration
they did publish a chart and this is the
advice to parents across the u.s they're
telling you as parents contact your ob
gyn and see if you can get free samples
of a baby formula now if you're unable
to locate baby formula that's joe
biden's solution to the baby formula
shortage crisis ask your doctor if they
have any samples in their office there
are reports joe that some of these
children have been hospitalized because
of the shortage donald trump taught you
what to do it's called operation warp
speed warp speed the production of baby
formula so that families don't have to
have a shortage like they currently have
this is really scary i even have more
bad news and it's even about to get
worse look at this jp morgan they are
now predicting gas prices about to
surpass six dollars a gallon nationwide
not california nationwide washington
state is now preparing for 10 a gallon
gasoline and keep in mind this does not
just impact uh everyday travel it
impacts our supply chain which is
already struggling it impacts deliveries
and manufacturing of every item we buy
and every store we go to and guess what
you'll pay even more for everything
now if he wants to joe biden can
stop this a
predictable gas hike easily and lower
prices and lower inflation and do it
expeditiously the oil and gas industry
is a futures market if traders believe
the future supply of oil and gas that
joe biden artificially reduce the supply
if they believe though it will increase
significantly
the price of crude oil will go down
almost immediately biden could restart
the keystone xl pipeline project
remember the premier in alberta said oh
it would be finished by now if joe
didn't stop it and we'd be importing 900
000 barrels of a canadian oil into this
country every day he could end his
administration's ban on new drilling and
exploration on federal lands joe can
lift his restrictions on offshore
exploration he can lift his restrictions
on fracking but he's not going to do any
of that not now and not ever he's more
afraid of the religious climate alarmist
cult that is his party
he cares more about them than we the
american people where are all the people
supposedly outraged over donald trump's
tweets uh
you know don't you care if you pay um
you know a million dollars uh for a
gallon of gasoline or six dollars or
seven dollars do you care that 66
percent of americans now are living
paycheck to paycheck do you care that
this is really destroying the poor the
middle class fixed income americans you
know i guess so long as the the
socialist climate psychos in the green
new deal wing of the joe biden party are
happy and content that's all that
matters and don't take my word for it
listens to biden's very own secretary of
the interior they're saying it
much to my chagrin
do you believe that gas prices are too
high
senator i
completely understand the crunch that so
many americans are under right now i
think that there that americans are
still recovering from this terrible
pandemic and there are a lot of other
world
events that are making things difficult
for all of us
so it sounds you're unwilling to say
that gas prices are too high because if
you thought they're too high i mean i
just wonder what your department has
actually done specifically
to lessen this terrible pain that
americans are suffering under these high
gas prices
we're doing
all we can senator
no they're not
you can't even answer a simple question
are gas prices too high the answer is
yes the solution is go back to donald
trump's energy independence policies and
once again make america
a net exporter of energy how about that
but this radical administration they
will do nothing they won't do a thing to
increase domestic production of oil and
gas instead
get ready because jimmy carter-style gas
rationing that could soon be a reality
you might not be able to fill up your
car except every other day you might be
rationed in terms of how much gas you
can buy according to reports this is now
under consideration at the highest
levels of the biden administration so is
this what building a better america
looks like joe because that's what you
promised we're going to have gas
rationing record-setting 40-year high of
inflation more poverty no law and order
high crime high record murder rates of
around the country open borders and no
baby formula now if joe had any dignity
any honor he would apologize
resign or just go back to the policies
that were working joe biden frankly
doesn't have it in him he's not bill
clinton clinton he's never going to say
the era of big government is over in the
end of welfare as we know it he is a
sleazy corrupt career washington insider
he has lied and cheated his way through
life his presidency is now no exception
remember joe biden promised you
inflation was transitory that was a lie
he promised to bring down gas prices
that was a lie he promised not to raise
taxes on anyone making under four
hundred thousand dollars a year that was
an outright lie in october of last year
he promised to fix the supply chain
crisis he said he'd do it 90 days that
was a lie and who forget who could
forget he promised to shut down the
virus well it's breaking out again the
latest wave hitting the entire country
that was a massive lie we just hit a
million culver deaths most of which
happened during his watch and his
administration he also promised not to
make vaccines mandatory in any way
they're mandatory he promised to visit
the southern border he's never been
there he promised to get the opioid
crisis under control it's never been
worse than it is today 291 days ago joe
promised not to abandon our fellow
americans behind enemy lines in the
islamic emirates of afghanistan that was
a lie he even promised to unite the
country said that over and over again
and he has not stopped vilifying half of
america ever since ultra magga is the
new mantra and here's a good one he
promised to always tell the truth that's
a lie too from the moment he cheated his
way through law school until right now
joe biden almost
never tells the truth and now with his
cognitive decline on top of everything
else biden's lies are more obvious than
ever and meanwhile you the american
people are now rightfully terrified
about the state of this country i am
concerned about the state of this
country i've never been this concerned
about america's economic health and
foreign policy disasters than i am right
now look at the cnn poll fake news
anyway they might have gotten this right
86 percent of americans are concerned
or scared about how things are going on
in the country you should be scared
these are dangerous times according to
quinnipiac their polls showing 26
percent of hispanic americans
only 26 percent approve of job joe's job
in office that's down from 55 percent
just last year his overall approval
rating is only 32 percent hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else